is that the Pete Davidson one the third
one or the fourth one yeah I hate PR
[ __ ] like this I know because I [ __ ]
fell for it like I saw that and every
part of me was like oh man that's crazy
so it's like Pete is sort of like
supposed to be like covering his face
and then watch her reaction here it's
like she's waiting for the [ __ ]
camera and then she moves hey and this
too I hate this is my least favorite
part
like they weren't thinking like they
didn't think about the [ __ ] glass
door that they just walked through there
should be like rules against this you
know what I'm saying just like there are
like rules for marketing what rules what
rules what rules you got guys like Pete
Davidson teaching men that all you do is
sleep around there's no honor in that
Laura's not even [ __ ] emrata he's
[ __ ] her what [ __ ] what [ __ ] have we
seen you're making many assumptions even
when you say that what is [ __ ] I just
cannot believe that they're actually
[ __ ] that's what I'm saying Jordan
thank you bro
nice to see you back on Twitter by the
way